for the criminal gangs people smuggling
is big business you only have to travel
to Cali to see the desperation that
drives migrants here to clamber into the
back of lorries in broad daylight
most are intercepted before they cross
the channel detected by tighter port
security and ironically it is precisely
this enhanced security at Cali and other
ports which is pushing increasing
numbers of migrants right into the hands
of the people smugglers
if you close down roots and make
relatively safe options impossible or
much harder you only drive people who
don't have real choices but to try to
make a journey onto much more dangerous
routes and of course more tragedies
result people smuggling gangs are
operating out of dozens of migrant camps
like this one in Dunkirk charging
according to the UK's National Crime
Agency between four hundred and thirteen
thousand pounds depending on the
complexity of the smuggling method in
their 2019 threat assessment the NCA
said the past year has seen increasing
use of higher risk methods of
clandestine entry these include the
movement of migrants including children
into the UK in containers refrigerated
HGVs
and small boats at a high risk to life
of those migrants smuggled this is
extremely dangerous these containers are
filled up and left in various places at
ports and facilities for days and so
those people would have had no idea what
was going on can you imagine anything
much more awful than what must have
happened to them and that's as a direct
result of the way these international
smugglers are behaving the tragedy in
Essex has echoes of a similar incident
in Austria four years ago in which 71
migrants suffocated in the back of a
lorry the last time something similar
happened here was the death of 58
Chinese migrants in a lorry in Dover in
we've been focused across the summer on
the issue of migrant incursions in small
boats in the English Channel but in
truth the use of lorries has always been
the main vehicle of choice for the
criminal gangs and despite the dangers
it's clear there is no shortage of
desperate people willing to take the
risk
mark white Sky News